let's talk about the Democratic National
Committee the Democratic National
Committee committee screwed Bernie
Sanders royally or nationally you could
call it in 2016 they have now adopted a
new rule that could conceivably impact
Bernie Sanders although it appears as
though there are specific reasons why it
will not let me explain the new rule
requires all Democratic presidential
candidates to be members of the
Democratic Party period and this is a
rule that would force candidates in
Democratic presidential primaries to
state that they are Democrats to accept
the party's nomination if they win the
primary like for example in 2020 and
also to run and serve as members of the
Democratic Party and as written the rule
says quote at the time a presidential
candidate announces their candidacy
publicly they must publicly affirm that
they are a Democrat each candidate
pursuing the Democratic nomination shall
affirm in writing to the national
chairperson of the Democratic National
Committee that they AR a member of the
Democratic Party B will accept the
Democratic nomination and C will run and
serve as a member of the Democratic
Party
so at face value it seems like a direct
response to the candidacy in 2016 of
Bernie Sanders write an independent who
decided to run in the Democratic
presidential primary the DNC is denying
that this is targeting Bernie Sanders
but it does relate directly to an anti
Bernie talking point that we heard in
2016 which was hey listen Bernie's not
even a real Democrat he's just running
for the Democratic nomination
there is another defense of all this
which is that if we want to get rid of
super-delegates there are those claiming
that this rule will make it easier to
get rid of super-delegates which is
something that Bernie Sanders wants we
actually just need more time to figure
out whether that's true but there is
understandable skepticism about whether
that's really the catalyst for passing
this rule in practice it does seem like
the rule is not going to affect Bernie
in 2020 if he runs because there's this
interesting thing that Vermont has done
at the state level
not passed a resolution recently which
says doesn't matter whether Bernie runs
as a Democrat or as an independent for
his Senate seat not for president but
for his Senate seat
Vermont passed a resolution which says
quote for all purposes and entitled to
all the rights and privileges that come
with such membership at the state and
federal level and what this means
assuming that the state resolution holds
is that Vermont is basically saying
Bernie Sanders is a Democrat and thus
the DNC wouldn't have a case to keep him
out of the primary in 2020 if Bernie
Sanders chooses to run I actually come
down somewhere else on this I've quite
frankly don't care whether or not Bernie
has a way around the rule the rule is
still the rule and it would affect the
Bernie Sanders were it not for the
Vermont resolution being passed and the
fact that Bernie Sanders has a way
around the rule doesn't mean we should
pretend for a second that this was a
logical thing for the DNC to do I don't
deny that there is a legitimate debate
that the DNC can have who's allowed to
run in the primary do you have to be a
registered Democrat you have to caucus
with Democrats if so for how long that's
a totally reasonable conversation to
have but to go through the 2016 election
debacle and to so clearly need to
regroup and rethink your strategy and
think of the best way to fight Trump and
to come away passing this rule as much
as lack of voter enthusiasm scares me
for Democrats in 2018 this stuff also
scares me for 2018 and I said from day
one that Tom Perez as DNC chair was a
disaster I said from day one that if the
Democratic Party wants to figure out
what to do they need to not do what
they've historically done which is to
just ignore the actual mistakes that
have been made there is a contingent
that is saying it's dishonest to claim
that this is all about Bernie I already
told you that whether or not there is an
actual question about the super delegate
process and eliminating super-delegates
being facilitated by passing this law
this for me is part of what the DNC has
done wrong since 2016 leadership roles
going to Clinton surrogates the 2016
fiasco not even really being addressed
in a serious manner and if your argument
is we should give the benefit of the
doubt to the DNC for this move and just
accept that they want to do what Bernie
wants which is to get rid of
super-delegates
what is the Democratic Party done to
earn the benefit of the doubt since 2016
I can't think of anything and I'm asked
I'm not asking rhetorically I'm actually
asking tell me what the DNC has done
since 2016 that warrants me giving them
the benefit of the doubt on this I can't
think of anything period